احتجزت السلطات الرومانية شخصية مثيرة للجدل على الإنترنت
ولاعب الكيك بوكسر السابق أندرو تيت
وشقيقه الأصغر تريستان تيت ،
وفقًا لمحامي الدفاع
عنهما ، بدأت السلطات الرومانية تحقيقًا في الاتجار بالبشر المنظم والاغتصاب ، لكنها لم تفرج عن أسماء أي
محامٍ من المشتبه بهم.  قال الأخوان لشبكة
CNN إنهم ليسوا رهن الاعتقال ولكنهم
محتجزون من قبل
السلطات الرومانية لمدة 24 ساعة
ولم يناقش المحامي أيًا من
الادعاءات وفقًا لبيان صادر
عن مديرية
التحقيق في الجريمة المنظمة
والإرهاب في رومانيا صدر يوم الخميس.
مذكرات اعتقال في خمسة منازل
وحصلت على أربعة مشتبه بهم من بينهم
بريطانيان ورومانيان ،
لم تذكر السلطات أيًا من المشتبه بهم الأربعة ،
لكنها أصدرت مقطع فيديو محببًا في بعض الأحيان خارج نطاق
التركيز عن المداهمات وفي
مقطع فيديو منفصل نشرته مكاتب الهوائي التابعة لـ CNN
3  من السلطات
يمكن اعتباره مرافقة  أندرو تيت
وشقيقه تريستان تيت في
سيارات الشرطة يوم الجمعة ، قام أندرو تيت بالتغريد
من اقتباس حسابه الذي تم التحقق منه.أرسلت The
Matrix عملاءهم إلى السلطات
تدعي أن المشتبه بهم الأربعة شكلوا
جماعة إجرامية منظمة امتدت
من رومانيا إلى بريطانيا والولايات
المتحدة لهذا الغرض.  بارتكاب
جريمة الاتجار بالبشر ،
تزعم السلطات أن اثنين من المشتبه بهم
ضللوا الضحايا للاعتقاد
بأنهم يعتزمون عقد زواج أو
ترتيب معاشرة أثناء
نقل الضحايا إلى رومانيا
ثم استغلالهم جنسياً في وقت لاحق
بالعنف الجسدي والإكراه ،
كما قالت السلطات إن  تم
اغتصاب الضحية في مناسبتين مختلفتين في
مارس 2022 من قبل أحد المشتبه بهم
، وتم التعرف على ستة ضحايا على الأقل
يُزعم أنهم تعرضوا للاستغلال الجنسي من
قبل جماعة إجرامية منظمة ،
وسيتم احتجاز المشتبه بهم الأربعة
لمدة 24 ساعة بعد
استجوابهم وفقًا للروماني.
السلطات Bianca nobelo CN  إن لندن